pas du tout c'est ce qu'on va faire là
un phénomène gérard darmon est ce que
même gérard darmon trouve qu'on voit
trop j'ai rarement dans cette émission
atteint un petit peu c'était moi je
trouve pas parce que en définitive je
les fais quoi trois fois l'année
dernière la wii passe pas énorme là non
mais comme il ya eu ce remix cet été a
été pratiquement toutes les semaines
paris un petit bout de nez petit clavier
un petit macho et le seul catherine
barma qui s'est occupée de ses remix est
folle de toi mais c'est très très bien
joué
d'ailleurs je le salue qui le redirai la
semaine prochaine oui est-ce que même
j'ai rarement a parfois besoin de faire
de la promo pour ses films marchent
alors là très franchement moi je pense
que la promo ne sert pas à grand chose
lorsque la bande annonce avant que nous
rejoindre et maintenant et qu'il irait
encore darmon oui au corps d'armand mais
nous rejoignent du monde entier les gens
à plus et c'est ce qui s'est dit ce
téléphone normal il ya internet ou via
berne chez ardisson il arrive qu est-ce
que même gérard darmon trouve qu'il est
plutôt beau gosse rarement en anglais il
ya ça
nenê est ce que même gérard darmon a
déjà pris des râteaux avec des filles je
peux monter une quincaillerie voilà le
bien sûr de lui mais là comme quoi comme
ça faut pas s'arrêter au râteau il faut
pousser plus loin jusqu'à l'appel
est-ce que même gérard darmon s'est déjà
fait trompé par une femme
ah oui même j'ai rarement oui mon blé
soit sa console wii
est-ce que même j'ai un amour à bgc des
moches aulas je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire parce que non
j'en ris l'élégant non non ça très
franchement ça veut bon moi
effectivement de voir une espèce de
monstre
bon sinon non mais moi j'ai pas cette
notion dirais pour avoir des images tu
pensé à qui il a un peu à la même place
bienvenue la photo de du nom et de
s'appeler l hermine de clermont tonerre
j'ai vu son mec et tous avons le symbole
alors ouais
est-ce que même gérard darmon a parfois
du mal à avoir des érections régulière
même gérard darmon est ce que même
gérard darmon a déjà eu des problèmes
d'éjaculation précoce balle à l'instant
est-ce que même gérard d'armand et si ce
bar est juste après avoir fait l'amour
bien sûr
même gérard darmon même jeu ça fait
plaisir aux gens chez eux parce qu' il
dise finalement on est tous pareils
oui hein il faut rajouter même à chaque
fois le snmg en armant a oublié le
prénom de ses ex à des mecs me dire les
histoires d'amour importante de ma vie
non non jamais convainc pas ce coin là
même est-ce que même gérard darmon a
déjà pris du viagra en cachette
non pas en cachette pour essayer pour
essayer je pensais que c'était genre
extra match aller à l'art pas mal pas
mal à mal oui bon pas très utile mais
pas mal est-ce que même si en armant
commence à avoir un peu de bide j'y fais
très attention et je réponds non
formellement se trouve pas mon bide là
est ce encore
et
jean normand
c'est maintenant les parents forestier
et caravage d'albi des jardins bon ça
fait un peu penser dans mamma tanga pas
bernard payer normalement